[MUSIC PLAYING]
SEB GRUBB: Firstly,
we will clarify what
is meant by shared storage--
also known as external storage.
Shared storage is
the area of apps--
can write files visible
to other apps, once they
get granted the reader right
external storage permission.
Functions that return locations
within shared storage include--
getExternalFilesDirs, which
returns your apps files folder;
getExternalCachedDirs, which
returns your apps cache
file folders; and get
ExternalMediaDirs, that returns
your apps media folders.
Game developers may also
be interested in the OBB
directories returned
by getOBBDirs.
Now, let's dive down into
what the stored situation is
like currently on Android Pi.
On one hand, we have
internal storage,
which is private to your app--
meaning, other apps will never
be able to access data there.
Internal storage is thus a good
place for internal app data
that the user doesn't
need to directly access.
And on the other hand,
we have shared storage
that we just talked about.
It is a world-readable space
that can be viewed and modified
by the user and apps.
This is what you see when
you enable USB mass storage
and plug your phone
into a computer.
To see files in shared
storage or /SD card,
apps need the
storage permission.
For files written there, there
is no App-to-File attribution.
There's only one exception.
Shared storage contains
app-attributed directories
that do not need any permission
to be accessed by the owner
app.
These include the
directories returned
by the GetExternalFiles media
and CachedDirs functions.
No permissions are needed, since
these folders have a clear app
to follow ownership structure.
This ownership structure
ensures that the files
are cleaned on app uninstall.
So that was the
situation in Android Pi.
Storage is one of the
most popular permissions
used by Android apps.
And as a result, we've seen
apps behind in all kind of ways,
resulting in issues
such as this clutter.
In Android Q, we looked at how
we could improve shared storage
by abiding to three
principles that improve
the experience for users.
The first one is
better attribution.
Here, we're really
trying to solve clutter
by avoiding files
lingering around on disk
once an app is uninstalled.
So in Q, when shown,
the system knows
what files belong to what apps.
This makes it easier for
users to manage their files.
And it means that, when
the app is uninstalled.
The Content [INAUDIBLE]
disk is cleaned up after.
There's obviously always
content that user will
want to possess post uninstall.
And we'll talk about this later.
The second principle
is protecting app data.
When apps write files
to external storage,
it should not be made
freely available and visible
to other apps.
You don't want
other apps looking
into what your app is doing.
So in Q, we're protecting
the app-specific data
by disallowing other apps
to view this content.
And the third principle
is protecting user data.
When you download
files, such as pictures
in your private conversations
or PDF of your bank statements,
you probably don't want all apps
to immediately see these files
and glean info
about your behavior.
In Q, we're making sure
users know when and what
files apps are accessing.
So sticking to these
principles means
that we are doing deep
changes in the ways
storage works in Android.
And we understand, it may
take some time for apps
to adapt to these changes.
But we think that,
in the long-term,
this will help make Android
a better platform for users
by providing better privacy
and storage management.
So with this in mind,
let's have a look at how
storage will work in Android Q.
So in Android Q, we're
doubling down on MediaStore.
The first change is that apps
can contribute to MediaStore
without any permission.
However, to view content
contributed by other apps,
the Storage permission
is required.
Apps can continue
to read and write
to their app-specific
directories.
But other apps, even if
they have obtained storage
permission, cannot view them,
unless the files are attributed
to them.
Apps will still be able to pick
files present anywhere on disk,
using the system picker,
which gives the app
and user a
transactional approach
to gain access to a file.
This makes access
more secure, since it
makes it more
explicit to the user
what file or files
are being accessed.
The final thing to
mention is the way
that internal storage
is not changing in Q.
So MediaStore is
not new to Android.
In fact, it's been
here since day one.
But Android Q-- we're
doubling down on MediaStore
and improving it.
So let's look more
into how it works.
So first question is--
what belongs in MediaStore?
MediaStore is designed
to hold content
that belongs to
the user and that
is available to other apps.
Thus, we recommend
only contributing files
when the user actively
expects it to be present
and the MediaStore collections,
such as explicitly taking
a picture in the Camera app.
The main types of media
present in MediaStore
are audio, video, and images.
So content contributed
to MediaStore
persists post app uninstall.
However, once the
app is uninstalled.
The content is considered
to be orphaned.
And if the same app is
then reinstalled later,
it will need to obtain
the storage permission
from the user to see content
it had previously contributed.
Now, what doesn't
belong in MediaStore?
This is a bit more
nuanced, since this
is more that user expectations.
But sometimes, it's pretty
obvious what doesn't belong.
App-specific media-- like
thumbnails, album art,
or stickers--
would usually not be
appropriate for MediaStore,
since they are not files a user
would want to see in other apps
or see persist post
app's uninstall.
In some cases, you may not be
sure where the content belongs.
For example, users
in chat apps may
exchange a large amount
of pictures that would
create clutter in MediaStore.
In these situations, we
suggest not contributing
to MediaStore straight away.
But wait until a user has
taken an explicit action,
such as selecting Save.
Now, in Android Q, we're
introducing a new collection
in MediaStore, which is
the downloads collections.
And this one works
a bit differently
than the previous three
that we mentioned.
This collection
is to place files
that don't fit into
other collections,
such as PDF files or any
other type of documents.
You can also contribute
content there
that would go into
other collections,
if you want it to be explicitly
part of a downloads collection.
In that case, they will also
be automatic contributed
to the other
appropriate collections.
So for example, if you download
a photo on your web browser
and add it to the
Downloads collection,
it will also be added to
the Images collection.
So like the previous
mentioned collections,
apps can view all the
content they contributed.
However, to view files
contributed by other apps,
a system picker--
invoked by Action Open
Document, for example--
is required to be used.
Another tip is not
always contribute data
to a downloads collection,
especially when the user might
want to control the
way it's stored,
such as saving a document.
In this case, launching
Action Create Document Intent
is recommended.
It lets users choose any
local network or cloud storage
provider location.
So this was a quick overview
how MediaStore works.
And I'm going to hand
you over to Jeff, who'll
give you more details of
how to contribute and query
MediaStore.
Thanks, Jeff.
JEFF SHARKEY: Thanks.
Thanks, Seb.
[APPLAUSE]
So as Seb mentioned,
one of the big changes
that we're making
in the Q release
is we're giving you
developers the opportunity
to contribute
items to MediaStore
without needing the
storage permission.
You can now insert, modify,
and delete any content
that you own yourselves
into MediaStore.
Only when you want
to work with content
that has been contributed
by other applications
do you need the storage
runtime permission.
We think this is going to
be a great change for apps
like photo or camera apps,
because you don't need
the storage permission anymore.
You can capture that image and
then save it into MediaStore.
And you won't need that
runtime permission.
As Seb also mentioned--
things that you contribute
to these common collections,
it's your way of saying,
this content
belongs to the user.
And it's intended to
persist beyond the lifetime
of your application.
So if the user
uninstalls your app,
that data is going
to be preserved.
So let's take a look at an
example of how this works
in practice with some code.
As Seb mentioned, MediaStore has
been around since Android 1.0.
So some of the APIs that
you're seeing on screen--
you've already been
working with today.
I'll focus on a
handful of places
we've added new
special behaviors
that can help make it
a better experience.
So here, the code
sample on the slide--
we're creating a ContentValues
to contribute a new image
that we're working with.
In the Q release,
all we need to do
is specify the display name and
the MIME type of the content
we're working with.
In this case, it's
just a JPEG image.
The new thing that's
highlighted on screen here--
this is a new feature
in the Q release--
the Is Pending flag.
When you insert an item--
like, when you inserted item
that is marked as pending,
by default, it will be hidden
from other applications
on the device.
When they go query
MediaStore, they're
not going to see that
item that's pending.
This gives you, as
the developer, a way
to temporarily work on that item
until you're ready to reveal it
to other apps on the device.
An example here might be if
you're a web browser working
on a long-running
download, where
you may switch between
mobile and Wi-Fi networks.
You can insert that downloaded
item, mark it as pending.
You can slowly work-- maybe
over 15 to 20 minutes--
however long it takes
to download that item.
And once you're
finished, that's when
you can set that
Is Pending bit back
to 0 to reveal it to other
applications on the device.
So back to our example here--
we have our content values
inserting something
that's pending.
I don't believe we have
our content resolver.
And we're going to be working
with the primary external
storage volume.
Content resolver.insert--
you've probably already
been using that today.
This is what's going
to insert a record
to say that you want
to work on this item.
It's reserving a space
for you to insert.
Now, that we have that item,
the result of that Insert call
was a new specific URI that
has been allocated just
for you to work on that item.
With that item URI, you can
now open a file descriptor--
in this case, for
write access here.
And you can stream
contents into place.
So we've highlighted
some of the details here.
If you need to, you
can also do that up
in managed code in Java.
You can also use that file
descriptor to go across JNI
and contribute data,
if you have native code
in your application.
At some point, we'll be finished
with the file descriptor.
We'll close it.
And now it's time to reveal
that to the other apps
on the device.
And that's as simple as
clearly not that ContentValues,
setting that Is
Pending bit to 0,
and then calling
Content resolver.update.
Once you make this
call, that's going
to cause it to become visible
to the other apps on the device.
So that was a simple example.
Let's look at some
more complex ways--
some new features that
we've given to you
to work with in MediaStore.
You now have the ability
to influence directories
of where things are stored on
these external storage devices.
In the simple
example that we just
looked at a few moments ago, the
operating system automatically
picks a safe default location.
Because we were inserting
an image/JPEG object,
the OS will put it in the
Pictures directory by default.
Similarly, if we
were inserting--
say-- an audio type
of file format,
we would automatically insert
it into the Music directory
on the device.
So we're helping set
some good defaults.
But you also have the
ability to influence if you
want a specific directory.
And this is the new
Relative Path column, which
is part of the public API.
You can set this
value to control where
those files are placed on disk.
We'll give an example of
that in just a moment.
Similar to these two columns,
both the Relative Path
and the Display Name--
you can use them when
you're inserting content.
But you can also
use them later on.
Once you've published content,
if you need to move it around
on disk, you can call
Content resolver.update
with those columns.
And the OS will now move the
content on disk on your behalf.
So zooming out a
little bit more--
we've talked about
influencing directories
of where the content lands.
In Q, we've also given
you more capabilities
to control which storage
device it lands on.
This is particularly
useful for Android devices
have that have multiple
shared storage locations.
They may have a
built-in shared storage.
But they also may
have an SD card slot,
where the user has
inserted something.
Starting in Q, you now
have the flexibility
to control which device you
want that content to land on.
Earlier we mentioned the
Volume External Primary.
That's the volume name of
that primary storage device.
You can also call a new API,
Get External Volume Names.
And this will enumerate
all of the possible storage
locations that are available
for your application to use.
Once you've selected one
of those volume names,
it's easy to start working
with that collection,
using the various
Get content URI
methods that you'll find across
the collections in MediaStore.
So if we pick a secondary
storage device--
if we discover it--
we can go past that
as the argument
to the Get content URI--
say, for example-- for
the Images collection.
That will allow us
to work with images
that are present on that
secondary storage device,
such as an SD card.
So let's take a look
at an example of both
of these advanced concepts
together in one example.
So the first thing we talked
about was that Relative path--
being able to influence
where things land on disk.
Here, we have a simple music
file that we're inserting--
MySong.mp3.
The relative path here--
we're asking for it
to be placed under Music,
My Artist, My Album.
Something worth noticing-- to
call back to Seb's point that
he made earlier--
one of our goals in Q is to help
ensure that the user's content
is organized on their device.
And so what this means-- that
top-level directory-- we're
going to help make
sure that it's placed
in a reasonable location.
So here, we're inserting an
MP3 file-- an audio file--
into the Music directory--
the top-level directory.
The OS is going to allow this,
because the content type makes
sense.
If, for example, we were
trying to insert this MP3 file
into the user's
Pictures collection,
that doesn't make sense.
That's disorganized.
And so the OS would throw
an exception back to you.
So just those three
common collection
types that we discussed--
Audio, Video, and Images--
there's a handful of locations--
top-level directories--
that are allowed
for each of those.
You can find, in the developer
documentation, more details.
But it's our way of helping keep
the user's content organized.
All right-- so in this
example, that relative path--
we've selected Music,
My Artist, My Album.
Just like we did before,
we're going to use Insert.
But the second
half of the slide--
this is where we're
going to select
a specific secondary
storage device.
We're seeing what volume
names are available.
And the ellipses there--
it's up to you and
your application.
But you could go
and prompt the user
to select one of those storage
devices that are available.
Or you could have settings
deep inside of your application
where you let the
user pivot and choose
one of those storage devices.
Either way, when you've
made your selection,
here's where you
pass that volume name
into the Get Content URI.
And this is what's
going to allow
us to work with the
audio collection
on a specific storage device.
And then the final
call will actually
insert that and work with it.
So we talked quite a bit
about contributing content.
Let's shift gears and
talk about discovery--
if you'd like to
consume the content
or list it or display
it to the user.
Thankfully, the APIs you've
been working with today--
content resolver.query--
those will
continue to work with
these collection types.
So you can query-- find items
in the user's Images or Music
collection.
The one thing we're
changing in the Q
release-- we're
strongly recommending
that you switch to using content
resolver.openfile descriptor
when you want to work with
one of those particular items.
And the reason is,
the data column,
which has been there for many
years, has now been deprecated.
And we'll get into
a little bit more
later today on why
that's deprecated.
But the best practice that
we're encouraging developers
to move towards is using
Open File descriptor instead.
You'll get back a
partial file descriptor,
be able to send that either to
managed or down to native code.
So it's quite flexible.
As we mentioned
earlier, by default,
applications that
query this collection
won't see any pending items that
other applications are still
working on.
If users expect to
see those pending
items in your application,
you can still modify the URI
that you're about to query
to request that those pending
items be included.
One thing to note
is that, for each
of the items that is
being contributed,
we now track who
contributed it--
who the owner is of those items.
What this means is--
while an item is pending,
only the owner of that item
can work with the content.
They're the only ones
that can read or write
the contents of the file.
Only when they've
published it, when
you've cleared
that pending flag,
is it available for other
applications to see.
The reason that's relevant here
for the set Include Pending--
you'll be able to see
that other people are
about to contribute items.
You won't be able
to open those items
until they've been published,
because they're still
under construction.
Here's an example of how to
use these things in practice.
So here, we have a normal
collection-- the users Video
collection.
We've gotten our Get
Content URI from that.
But in our case,
we'd like to see
some of that pending content.
The set Include Pending--
we pass in the URI.
And we get back a slightly
modified version of that URI.
It's modified to
tell us, as the OS,
that you'd also like to
see the pending items.
Once you've run a query with
a cursor that comes back,
that gives it the opportunity
to show those items to the user
and pick one to work with.
Open File Descriptor
is another great choice
here for a specific
item that you've found.
With that partial file
descriptor that comes back--
many of our utilities
across the US,
whether it's Image Decoder
or other media player APIs--
they're ready and willing
to accept that partial file
descriptor.
Finally, one side note at
the bottom of the slide--
there's a new API in Q--
content resolver.loadThumbnail.
And this is designed to
provide an optimized path
for loading a small lightweight
thumbnail in your app.
You can imagine,
if you're scrolling
through a large
list of contents,
you don't want to open the
large heavyweight items just
to generate a small thumbnail
to show to the user.
So this new Load Thumbnail API--
for a specific item, you pass
in the item you're interested in
and the size--
roughly, the dimensions
on-screen that you're
looking to show to the user.
Internally, in the OS,
we'll do the hard work
of helping resize that image to
make it nice and lightweight.
And we'll also
handle caching that,
so that we ensure
that it's fast for you
to reopen in the future.
And we'll also handle-- if the
content has changed over time,
we'll automatically
invalidate that thumbnail
and regenerate it.
So it's designed as a great
best practice API to use,
if you want to just show
lightweight thumbnails.
So now that we've
discovered items,
let's talk about editing items.
A change that we're
making in the Q
release-- we've
already described items
that you contribute.
You have full read, write,
and delete access to the items
that you have contributed.
However, items that belong
to other applications,
you'll only have read access to.
If you'd like to be able to
modify or write those items,
you'll need to involve the user.
And we're doing this--
any of the operations
on Content Resolver
that work with modifying files,
whether it's Update, Delete,
or opening a file descriptor
for the right mode--
all of those-- they
will check internally
if you have the right
permission to that item.
If you don't have
the permission,
it'll throw back a new type
of exception-- a Recoverable
Security Exception.
We'll dig into, in
a moment, an example
of what this looks like.
The easiest thing-- when
you receive one of these,
it's telling you,
it's an exception.
You don't have access now.
But if you involve
the user, the user
is able to grant you that
access so that you can have
both read and write access.
Let's take a look at an example.
Here at the top,
we're attempting
to delete a specific photo.
But we don't have to
know ahead of time
if we have that
permission or not.
If we have the permission
to delete, we'll succeed.
If we don't, it'll throw that
recoverable security exception
back at us.
And it's up to us to
involve the user in whatever
way is most appropriate.
In this example
on the code slide,
we're going to be
showing an alert dialog
to the user in our application.
This alert dialog-- when
the user presses the button,
we're going to launch
that PendingIntent that's
included in that
exception, which
is going to show a dialog
to the user, letting them
grant that access
to your application
for that specific item
that you're interested in.
So we get that exception.
There's a nice message.
Under User Action,
it has a title.
And there's also
that pending intent.
That action item or
that action intent
is a pending intent that you
can send to involve the user.
The alert dialog
is just one example
here for the purposes of
our presentation today.
But depending on the
design of your application,
you may also want to show
a notification to the user
if you're trying to do
this in the background.
There's many ways
to get the user
to launch the pending intent.
So it's quite flexible in
letting you figure out the best
way to involve the user.
So shifting gears
a little bit more--
one thing we're focusing
on in Q is helping
protect location metadata.
As Seb mentioned, one
of the critical features
we're building in Q is
helping protect users' privacy
and security.
And what this means
is-- normally,
when you go interact
with an image file,
we'll be redacting any
location information included,
such as the latitude
or longitude,
in the EXIF metadata.
So if users expect to see
the location information
inside of your app, you
can add a new permission--
Access Media Location--
to your manifest.
When you open that file, we
will not redact the information.
It will allow you to see
the full latitude longitude.
But what we're doing--
it's by default.
We're protecting
that information.
You'll still be able
to see the other EXIF
metadata, such as the shutter
length, shutter speed,
other information about
the date-time taken.
But only the location data
is going to be redacted.
On MediaStore, there
are two columns,
Latitude and Longitude,
that in previous releases
have been indexed.
Now, in the Q
release, you'll find
that those columns are null.
And they're empty.
Instead, if you need access
to the location metadata,
you can use the EXIF
interface tool instead.
Let's take a look
at this in action.
So in this case, if your app
actually needs access to that
location information--
if the user expects it--
you would just add a
user's permission tag
to your manifest.
Note that this is not
a runtime permission.
It's purely a signal
to us on the OS
that you're interested
in this information.
Simply by adding it, it
will grant you that access.
So by virtue of requesting
that permission, when
you go to open--
in this case-- the
openInputStream
for a particular photo,
you can pass that
into the EXIF interface.
That's a class that's been in
the OS for a couple of years.
But it's also available in
the jetpack support libraries.
That will help decode that
information in the metadata
and give you access to
that latitude and longitude
information to help
you build your app.
So we've talked so far about
the three important principles
that we've been
building into Q--
helping protect user's data,
helping protect your data,
and giving better
accountability to the user
over who's responsible
for putting
that data on the device.
In order to deliver on
those goals, starting in Q,
we have to start restricting
the direct raw access
to the underlying file system.
And we're doing
this using a feature
we're calling Scoped Storage.
Let's dig a little bit
more into what that means.
This has changed over the
course of our beta releases
this year--
Beta 1, Beta 2,
and also in Beta 3.
What we're going to
be talking about today
is the final design
that we're going to be
shipping in the Q release.
So in the Q release, if your
app is targeting an older API
level, below or before Q,
you will see no changes.
You will continue to retain full
access to the shared storage
device--
that raw kernel file
system level access.
However, once your
application targets Q,
it's put into this Scoped mode.
And what this
means-- it no longer
has direct raw file system
access to the SD card.
One note is-- you will
continue to receive
these package-specific
directories.
You'll continue to
have raw direct access
to those directories.
These are the ones that Seb
mentioned at the very beginning
of the presentation--
those best-practice APIs--
so context.GetEsternalFilesDirs,
CachedDirs,
MediaDirs, and ObbDirs.
All of those directories--
because they have your package
name in them, you'll continue
to enjoy full raw system
access to those.
It's only outside
of those locations
that the kernel will
start returning either
a File Not Found exception, if
you're running managed code,
or an EPERM error not, if you're
running down a native code.
Instead, if you'd
like to interact
with content outside of those
package-specific directories,
we're encouraging you to use
MediaStore or the Storage
Access Framework instead.
Let's take a look at example--
so when is it appropriate
to use one versus the other?
We've talked about
both interchangeably.
MediaStore is good for
those strongly-typed content
that we talked about--
images, video, and audio.
But it's not a good fit for
other content types, like Word
documents, Excel
documents, or PDF files.
Instead, we want you to launch
an intent, like the Storage
Access Framework, to let
the user pick exactly what
content you work with.
These intents have been around
since the Kit Kat release.
You can call them using Action
Open Document or Action Create
Document.
And these have two benefits
for you as developers.
One is it's a whole
lot less code for you
to build and maintain.
Instead of building your
own file-picking experience
that the user has
to learn when they
come into your
application, they're
now presented with a
single uniform experience
across all apps when they want
to pick content to work with.
So right-- to contrast,
MediaStore is a good fit
for those well-defined
collections--
Images, Video, and Audio.
But also, MediaStore
is limited to only work
with local content that
is built into the device.
It doesn't offer any access
to other storage locations
off the device.
That's another powerful
feature of the Storage Access
Framework.
It gives the user
the ability to choose
to work with a
network file share,
such as in a small
business environment,
or a cloud storage provider.
This is an open platform.
So starting in Kit Kat, there
was the Document Provider API.
If you find yourself--
if you'd like
to provide a place
to store content,
you, as a third-party
developer, can
go build one of these
document providers
and appear in the
list, right next to any
of the other storage locations
that are available to the user.
So we think it's quite
powerful and flexible.
So we've also heard,
loud and clear from you,
as our developer
community, when we started
initiating these
changes, that taking away
that access required a lot
of changes on your part.
And this is why, as we
announced a couple weeks ago
in a blog post, we've relaxed.
We've relaxed the requirements
for the Q release.
So Scope storage--
when you target Q,
you have the opportunity
to temporarily opt out.
In our testing internally,
the majority of applications,
when we enabled Scope storage,
we found that they worked.
There's only a small
handful of cases,
where applications may not be
following our best practices,
that we found there were bugs.
So we hope that, as you
target the Q release,
you'll attempt to keep
Scope storage enabled.
And we hope that you'll be able
to find that it just works.
If you don't-- if
you encounter bugs,
we'd like to ask you
to do two things.
First, you can use this Manifest
flag to temporarily opt out.
And second-- please, reach
out to us and our developer
advocates so we can understand
more about your use case
and make sure that we can
work together to solve it.
The one final thing that we
want to make really clear
is that this is only temporary.
This Manifest flag will not work
in next year's major platform
release.
And part of that is
our goal of trying
to deliver on that full
message of delivering
the user privacy and security.
So thank you for
your help with that.
Let's take a look at an example
of how you would use this.
A note is that
some of these names
have changed over time
between the beta releases.
What we're looking at
on the slides today
are the final
attribute and method
names that will ship
in the final Q release.
The names are going
to be slightly
different in the
Beta 3 release that
was just launched yesterday.
So here, we're
targeting the Q release.
And using this Manifest flag,
we can temporarily opt out.
We can say, we'd like to go
back to the old storage world.
You can add this.
One example that we've
heard from developers is--
maybe you're embedding
a shared library
from another developer that
you don't have the ability
to quickly change.
It's code that you don't own.
This might be a good reason
to add this flag temporarily.
But please, reach out to us
and that library developer
to see if we can work
together to migrate
towards best practices.
The second code snippet
on the slide here is--
we recognize that your
app may be running
under either of these modes.
It may be in the Legacy mode
or in the new Scoped mode.
And the method
here on Environment
lets you check to see
which of those modes
your application
is running under.
One thing that's worth
noting is that, on Android,
we always preserve the
original level of access
you had when your application
was first installed.
So if you were installed on a
P device, where you expected
to have full access
to the storage device,
your app will
continue to have that,
even after the user
upgrades to the Q device
or after they've
upgraded your app.
So you'll preserve that.
You'll have that
access you've always
had-- that [INAUDIBLE] when
you were first installed.
This method is the
good way to check
to see which of those states
that you're running under.
So thank you for taking
the time to understand
more of our motivation
about why we are
making some of these changes.
We understand they're hard.
And hopefully, we
can work together
to be able to help improve
the privacy and security
of our users together.
Both Seb and I will be at the
Sandbox tomorrow at 1:30 PM,
if you have any additional
questions for us.
With that-- thank
you for your time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]